feel
not just
Houston so welcome everyone to this last
meeting of the city council for 202
three um I particularly want to welcome
those people who have joined us in live
stream um and I also particularly want
to welcome um Santa Claus who's joined
me joined us on my left hand side here
today and very glad that he shaved for
the occasion but to see him here in
place of Michael
Morris um and using Michael's name
tag so we have apologies from um Noby
Clark um who is in Wellington on Council
business we also have apologies from um
counselor Bole and also from Evelyn cook
and we have a apology for leaving early
from Alex cracket who I think Alex
you're leaving at 5:00 p.m. is that
right just after just after 5:00 p.m.
okay thank you um we have no one on Zoom
today uh we have no one on public public
forum um we have two major late items
move the apologies H sorry will someone
move that we received apologies thanks
Grant and seconded thank you those in
favor say I I I thank you we have um two
major late items we have the first one
which will be heard in public which is a
recommendation from finance and project
committee
um the reason that that was not on the
agenda is that it came be hand after the
publication of the agenda but will
someone move that we um receive those
minutes yeah or that we are able to
receive those minutes thank you Al
second second thank you all in favor say
I I I against carried we also have a
second um late major late item uh which
will be heard in public excluded which
is in resp ECT to the D Street Hospital
site um the reason that that's not on
the agenda the item came in hand after
the publication of the agenda and the
reason it's been held in public
exclusion um is for uh reasons of um
commercial
confidentiality and accordance with
Section 7.2
B2 of the Local Government Act move that
we accept the late
item thank you all those in favor say I
I thank
you so we turn now to the
agenda and I note that we have um
1,350 pages to work through so if we got
a pheral clip of 1 minute per page we
should be finished by lunchtime tomorrow
so I hope everybody's brought the
signages with them we'll try to go a bit
faster than that
so the first item the minutes of the
connected miru joint committee meeting
held on Monday the 20th of November will
somebody move that we receive those yeah
I can
second
seconded Alex all those in favor say I I
I we have the minutes of the risk and
Assurance committee meeting um held on
the 21st of November move those
second all those in favor say I I
I against
carried we have the minutes of
the we have the minutes of the meeting
of council held on 28th November was
someone move that we receive those yeah
I can thank you grant second and bar all
those in favor say I I against carried
we have minutes of the community
well-being fund subcommittee meeting
held on 1th November um I would normally
ask Trish to move those but Alex was
there so Alex you move
those thank you all those in favor say I
I I against
carried we have the minutes of the
infrastructure committee meeting held on
the 5th of December and also a
recommendation from that but we'll take
the two separately rangy but if you I'll
move the minutes and I'll also move at
the same time that Council uh adopt the
updated draft privacy policy as in the
recommendation okay second it will you
second both yeah yeah is there any
discussion on the uh policy
recommendation and if not then all those
in favor say I I against carried
we have the minutes of the creative
Community
scheme um those Pro for pardon on moved
in Pro forer I was an apology for the
meeting then okay um so moved and
proformer by Daren because they actually
as no one here who was at that meeting
um will someone second on sign byis yes
okay thank you all those in favor of
receiving those minutes Pro former I I
those
against carried
so we have the minutes of the hearing
for the Queens Park
reclassification held in the 12th of
December saved thank you will someone
second that
okay thank you Ria all those in favor
say I I
against carried
we have the minutes of the community
well-being committee meeting held on the
12th of December and I will take these
two matter separately D you move the
minutes y received I'll second thank
Grant all those in favor say I I I
against
carried we have a recommendation from
the meeting um which goes to
item 9
points1
uh do you wish to move those done yes I
do yeah really council is in in two
options when it gets to that point to
either receive them or reject them and
start the process again yeah yeah so the
wording of four is to agree that if the
objections are not accepted so there is
the by implication of choice any way
that it's
worded well the recommend yes uh the
recommendation of the committee was that
the objections were not not
accepted okay so can we
reward that point four I don't think
it's quite accurate the way that if we
are going to move and accept because if
we the objections so it should read the
objections were not accepted for the
following
reasons
the
we'll just take out the word take out
the word I'll take out the
word
yeah
okay and it is it is the needs to come
out as well and then it's accurate to
agree that the objectives were not
accepted for following
reasons yeah good to go good to go so
everybody happy with W Us in Earth yeah
y
um I might just uh point out actually
point in case well everybody will have
read it but the uh
five a no a that we now have the
authority as Council to approve that
without separately having to go to
Department of Conservation that's right
yes okay so I think we had a move on
second we just need them to confirm that
they're heavy conf the changes yes y
thank you everybody happy with that um
so on the basis of that we're taking
points 1 to 7 at the same time um all
those in favor say I I I against carried
thank
you we have the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of council held on
12th of December will someone move that
we receive those y thank you grant is
the second there second thank you Ria
all those in favor say I I I against
carried so we have a temporary road
closure proposal next and Doug you're
here to speak to that normally these
would go to the infrastructure committee
first wouldn't they was it a timing
reason for not at all no I couldn't
explain why it's here okay a timing
reason Mr chair otherwise it would have
to go to
infrastructure this is I think due
before the um infrastructure committee
is
meeting on the 23rd of January I see
okay that explains it okay Doug well
obviously um I think the paper pretty
much speaks for itself but please you
know if you wish to summarize it
certainly does I I just think um we can
take the report as read um it's a a good
use of new infrastructure to be fa it's
what it's here for so uh yeah I would
support this
whole are there any questions of
Doug no I I'm happy to move there a
question I think from Alan
sorry I had a question oh you had a
question and moving it I ju Just some
feedback from Recently um around the
fact that we're not getting as many of
these events in es Street as we were
hoping for they they seem to be
happening quite regularly in Dawn Street
partially I think I can answer the
question by partially going it's Sur
hoso which isn't
necessarily an esque Street thing
but
I mean the the automatic ballards are on
ES Street for a reason
so so who makes the the decision is the
event organizer or do we make the
decision whether it's going to be one of
the other this bar request the event
organiz
that okay so presumably if we wish to we
could encourage them to look at EST stre
but I don't know whether that's a
general
view um is it you view done um it was
simply some feedback that I received
after there was a road closure granted
for RK Street or comment made by a
couple of
counselors anybody wanted it closed off
to be a mall so yeah R do you want to
comment on that I think the concern was
if it wasn't a street that it would
compete with our retailers too too close
to them that the preference was Dawn
Street what there no food retailers and
Dawn Street are you telling me no I'm
not it's not my wdding it's what the
public come back and said that that the
competition was for the food holders and
an EST stre that was too close for their
businesses whereas Dawn Street was kind
of over that way would allow more food
trucks and things like
that streets being full of
hospit that's what sorry full of
hospitality restaurants and bars okay so
look I think it's I mean on the one hand
you could say it's best left to the um
event organizer to know which is best
for them I think if we see a trend
emerging that we're uncomfortable with
then we can always go back and encourage
think again Alan same thing and my
question is that um Dawn Street I mean n
Street's been designed for this type of
thing and to be fear like the shops are
shut at 5 to9 but there's actually
people that are residents who can't get
access to the where they live in Dawn
Street it just makes no sense to me and
they keep on using my car park and cing
my toilets in building that we have down
Dawn Street and I won't allow that again
so don't know why they don't do it on EX
Street okay you got toilets you got
everything everything's
there and as a you know you know as a
retailer in that area myself I I welcome
more I don't I don't think it's it's not
not not a threat to ask y it's an
advantage R do you want to speak to the
same subject or yeah you know um
obviously you read the news um New
Year's Z Dawn Street is the place to
be it's the same thing there's a massive
obviously the roads Clos for it's a car
park it's a car park one is it yep right
right but again doesn't actually say
that as a car park but maybe in the fine
print in the dawn street car park I
signed the liquor license right okay
right Dawn Street Car Park isn't the
Wilson Oh former Wilson's one that's now
I the one next to the langlands next to
the langlands okay cool none of the
other streets closed up no okay but
obviously again Dawn Street good SP the
hos yeah okay Leslie uh thanks Mr chair
it's I was just going to contribute that
it has been obious at the other Dawn
Street events that the EST Street es
Street retailers food retailers have
been quite happy to have signs out
suggesting that people might like to
also visit es
Street it doesn't sound to me like they
particularly thinking there's there's
competition and we're obviously getting
the indication that this some preference
for the other events of this nature to
be in is street so I think it is well
worth
investigating um that happening more
regularly in es Street it was what we
all thought was going to
happen Alex pretty much what Ley said I
think this is a really quick and easy
fix very simple conversation hey we
would just like to see more hip and
Street as well can you give us a
calendar of what that's going to look
like over the next 12
months everything's
TT traffic management yeah through self
chair I'm happy to take it on board and
take that back to the event organizers
because that is part of the city
activation component and that is
something we can give an indication back
to uh Great South about um how we would
like the events to go forward from a
council perspective and just working
through what that balance is going
forward so I can get something on that
to come back to council um in the New
Year okay thank you so given that
qualification um are people happy to is
somebody happy to move that thank you
Dan somebody second yeah I can second
thank you grant so we are um moving all
three recommendations on page 83 of
board books um all those in favor say I
I I those against
I
okay Alan I I mean you don't have to
give a reason but is it because of the
Dawn Street say okay then thank you it's
just just so we understand I well you
need traffic management and down street
you don't need traffic Management in
this street there's money to be saved
okay so I mean I think that's I think we
probably had that point and Michael's
going to take it up so but I understand
the reason you're doing it okay thank
you so that we then move to the elected
and appointed members attendance
register for the period to when's it
start is it June to December or
essentially okay for the second half of
the year
basically it's
received yeah I I think um let's of
questions so yeah um back when we last
had this come forward um we had the
discussion about how I put my apology
forward to the m and it wasn't recorded
i' I'm still for that month that I was
away in Europe still recorded here as
DNA when I had put in my apologies so
that hasn't been changed since we um had
that discussion last time this paper
came forward and the same for um
infrastructure committee literally the
paper that we just moved earlier that
records um my apology away for being
away on um Council business for young
elected members Network and recorded as
an apology rather than a way for local
government so I
just yeah every time this comes up
there's disc and I think the I don't
know if it was the last time it came up
at the time before Michael but I
certainly remember it once stage I asked
sting over there I I asked if we could
um perhaps distribute it a draft version
a couple of weeks before so that people
could um check it and correct or comment
or so I I think if we could maybe start
that process I think that'd be very
helpful thank you I absolutely take that
on board and apologies uh councelor
crackett we should have corrected that
um I'm not sure why that hasn't been
done um I would take that on board and
make sure that it is done and yes I
think C ating a draft in advance yeah is
helpful for everybody um but as ever if
there are apologies that you believe we
have missed on this please send them
through to me um and we can get them
corrected and I circulator corrected one
early in the new year I think there's I
mean this is obviously is just a record
of who's been where but it's a
historical document and therefore um you
know I think important that what is
actually received and approved is as
accurate as we can make it so what I'm
inclined to the Michael I don't know if
that's the right words is leave at the
table but I think if you bring it back
next time having had the opportunity for
members to come back and say hey look
this is wrong or you know I'm sure I
whatever so that we get it right before
we receive it very comfortable with that
um on that basis uh Mr chair and also
note uh the recommendation there is to
receive the attendance register July
2023 that should have been December
2023 um that as a discrepancy um clearly
um it's nearly the end of the year I beg
your Indulgence and apologize and we
will bring it back um refreshed ready to
go in January Sant I want a special
Christmas present before I get here just
one could you put names at the top of
every page yes I was going to say that
too yeah yeah yeah because when you look
at an iPad you actually have to count
along the roads to find your name it's
really quite
awkward table going through months and
months and months historic minutes to
double check whether or not you were you
know it's just frustrating process so I
think we we've agreed that we leave this
paper on the table make it can bring it
back next time in the meantime if
there's any value in leaving in the
table is that people will actually check
their columns and be satisfied um when
it comes back next time we just have to
assume that any corrections that people
have have already been made um and we'll
receive it next time it comes okay
perfect thank you thank
you so that takes us
to um the paper that takes up 1100 Pages
or 1200 pages of the the agenda um so I
don't know if even know I want to say
welcome rihan
that's it's an ex it's an extremely
dense paper but I mean that in the
nicest
way I will take that in good part um
thank you yes just before you
start
um can I just summarize where I
understand that we are ranning and you
can just correct me for the benefit of
members so I I think this is a
culmination of a long-term plan and
budget process started a year ago and
since we started that process we've had
about 25 meetings I think um we started
with effectively a blank sheet and we um
considered what was desirable what was
essential and what was affordable and
what we've tried to narrow the you know
the choices down to are those things
which are highest priority and based on
highest priority and
affordability um now as I understand
that this is the penultimate stage of
the excise size and that once we have
approved this
paper that then forms the basis of what
goes to Auditors in the middle of
January the Auditors pretty quickly
actually turn that around and by the
time of the the January um council
meeting uh we see this we see it again
uh this time with the benefit of the um
comments by the uh comments by the
Auditors and at that point when we
approve it hopefully at that point that
is actually the last time we see it is
that have I described accurately what
the pro where we are the process almost
yeah so um this paper and the next one
on this agenda is the culmination you're
absolutely correct of all the council's
work over the last year um so I do
apologize for the length of the agenda
but it is all of the work that's been
done around this table and through the
whole business in terms of pulling that
direction into um bringing to you all
the materials that the Auditors need to
see the Auditors will um be here
assuming that we stay on the same track
and I'll speak to that shortly also um
for 5 weeks so we will come back with
the consultation Document Plus all the
supplementary material for adoption for
consultation on the current timeline at
the end of February you will unfort Ely
say it all again in the well fortunately
or unfortunately in the long-term plan
document itself which follows the second
audit so um that you will see it again
in February and then again in June for
the adoption of the long-term plan
document itself so all of these are if
you want to think of it in this way
there are the raw materials that will
form first the consultation document and
materials and then the ltp document
itself okay so the the the from here on
in council's view will
be advised by Auditors comments and then
advised by the consequence of
consultation but today um we are trying
to finalize the
input and we probably don't get another
opportunity after
this this is this is the last stage
before audit but there is opportunity
for further adjustments through January
and February is required and directed by
Council and ultimately you take based on
Auditor's comments based on Auditor's
advice and then obviously we consult But
ultimately you take the advice of the
community and then make the decision
that you believe is best through the
long-term plan so there are two more
decisions points okay okay so I just
wanted to get everybody in the same page
on just where we are in this process so
now you know if you want to take us
through the paper then I'll leave you to
do that this is as a very dense paper I
I I don't want to try to hurry it too
much because I think there are some
discussion points that we we have to
have so I suggest you do just work
through it Point by Point okay so um
then chair if it's okay with you what I
might do is start with just some minor
Corrections and an addition of a of a
proposed
recommendation um and then provide an
update on um the latest advice we have
around the audit process because I think
that it's relevant to this paper and
then work through the rest of the paper
if does that work for you um so Michelle
I think you have the taxed for the
corrections the first Corrections are on
um recommendation 4 and they are um due
to
um due to further budgeting information
that became available this week so
that's just a correction there two
Corrections um the first correction in
option one is relating to just where
we're at in terms of finishing the
rating model the rating model is always
the last thing to get finished um so we
just want a signal that is expected to
be around 0.5% it may be slightly lower
than that um on option two that is a a
incorrect statement that just needed to
be fixed it will remain at 22 units and
then the other correction to the paper
is the request for an addition of a
further resolution at the end of the
paper which is in regard to the latest
ministerial advice we have had regarding
three Waters regulatory um plans for
regulatory change so if if possible
chair speak briefly to that now want to
delete or do we want to delegate see
he's getting
deleted yes that should be delegate not
delete um I hope that's my
to appeared already so the
mination document okay is everybody
happy with the the addition of that
number
17 okay so chair with your um Direction
perhaps it makes sense to speak to Point
17 first and then work through the rest
of the paper are you happy with that
approach sure yeah so um we've just had
advice through on how the new government
intends to um deal with the issue of
timing around the regulatory changes
that they're intending to make in the
area of three Waters and the stage that
we're all at in the long-term planning
process so the department of internal
affairs is working on the draft
legislation at this point which is
intended to go through Parliament in
January and early February um so there
will be crossover period where um there
is essentially a a legal point where
it's unclear what
direction there are two pieces of
legislation one that's here at the
moment and one which will be coming and
the Auditors they legally must audit
what is there not what is coming so um
that's the advice that we're speaking to
at this point so essentially the
government um appears to be taking a
direction of trying to provide as many
options as possible for councils to take
so recognizing that everybody is in a
different situation in terms of three
Waters and what it means to the council
operations and the approach they've
taken to planning to the long-term
plan so you'll recall councilors that
all the way through the long-term
planning process we have been taking a
parallel planning approach in basically
anticipating that should there be a
change in government we may need to
Pivot um so we are we believe in a
fairly strong position to respond in now
in this situation essentially Patricia
and the team have modeled all the
budgets with three orders in um Erin and
her team have been planning in terms of
what they anticipate they would be able
to deliver and as you know through the
conversations that we've all been have
we we've been anticipating we would be
talking to the community about what
would need to be done in three Waters
irrespective of who would actually
deliver that so we are in a good
position given the options that the
government is putting forward so
essentially they are saying that they
anticipate post the legislation change
that all disclosures required in the
long-term plan should revert to the
local government act as it states at the
20 at
2021 so um we believe we're in a
position to do that in terms of our
three Waters program there are choices
in front of us in terms of how we
approach the ltp process so the first
choice is we can go with the standard
procedure um and we can follow all of
the normal audit stages and consultation
stages and proceed to the delivery date
which is required for the rate strike of
30th of June
2024 um that would as I've just outlined
before require two audit processes the
audit of the consultation document and
then following consultation the audit of
the long-term plan
itself there is a second choice um which
the government is saying we can make
which is no audit of the consultation
document so they're introducing that
option to allow a smooth process knowing
that there's complexity in front of all
of us in terms of what three Waters
means whether it's in or out um they are
advising that we should negotiate with
the Auditors around um a parallel
process of consultation and udit to
ensure that we are in good time in order
to adopt
ran and just to be clear there when you
say no audit of the consultation
document you mean in respect to three
water specifically no order at all no
but no order of any consultation no
ordit of the consultation document
essentially removing the first stage of
the ltp order entirely that that is an
option in front of us um and then
they're saying in order to ensure that
the audit which is normally much shorter
of the longterm plan itself can proceed
in time that we would need to start the
order in parallel with consultation so
that is one option Alex um is that
likely to result in less audit fees for
us is it possible to quantify how
much would certainly be something we
would discuss but we don't have that
information at this
point
so the question asked posed by number 17
then is
that question that the chief
executive may be allowed to make the
decision about which of those two
options we
follow I haven't there's more options
should I finish outlining the options
okay so then the next option um is to
defer adoption no later than the 30th of
September
2024 um and that is particularly
available for councils that are not in a
position to swiftly move to three Waters
in um and if that we if we did chose
choose that option then the annual
report would also be deferred and would
be adopted by the end of
December um the next option is that for
those councils which are have planned
purely for the status of under the
current legislation as it stands they
can go out and consult with no three
Waters and then they can add three
Waters in as best they can ahead of
adoption of the long-term plan and
finally the last option is if we started
with three orders in which is currently
legislatively not
correct they are intending to write into
the new legislation that neither are ltp
nor rates made in Reliance will be
invalid if we consult on that basis so
there's a number of different options in
front of us we are in the position to
respond and pivot in the direction that
makes most sense for this Council we are
probably in quite a um strong position
compared to most other councils around
that um
and until we've had the conversations
with the Auditors and this is why we're
advis requesting a delegation to Michael
we're not in a position to discuss the
things like councelor cck is Raising
around audit fees which are important to
consider but also the whole timeline and
delivery um because there are certainly
benefits for the rest of council
business the longer the long-term plan
goes on the more staff resource it takes
from other things um so there are
certainly benefits to staying on track
in terms of the time frame so it's uh um
obviously I personally support the
number 17 and I think you know we we'll
get to that in a minute but uh what it
what it seems to me is that for the past
12 months we in terms of both Council
and officers have worked very very hard
to get to the point that we have and we
have thought through I think correctly
um you know what might happen at this
juncture and what the options are and
we've probably chosen the correct option
in terms of the
likelist I mean I would be and I'm not
trying to take decision away from Mel
it's M's decision when he thinks about
the the broadest implications but to be
honest I I just want to keep the
momentum going that would be you know my
view let's let's not do anything that
puts in jeopard day the risk we going to
go back over a whole lot of stuff that
we've just done over the past 12
months uh through yourself chair um the
reason we need this um delegation in
place is because we need to work through
a whether AIT what that would look like
um audit if they begin in their normal
process which would the middle of
January um would be audit if they were
to audit the consultation document um as
it stands that would be um from their
perspective not compliant with
legislation and that would be the T they
would have to take because that is the
requirement they have to take the
current legislation into account um so
we would need to work through with them
so they can get get confidence through
their audit process into the final
documentations that end up um going
through into our ltp so they will be
doing that as part of that process to
validate numbers and detail relation to
that but they cannot give us an audit
opinion on the consultation because they
would be auditing it at a time when
legislation's not
confirmed thanks J um just backing up
Michael considering the timing we're now
in December and the timing of any new
legislation this is the most
practical um resolution we could pass so
to me it's a it's a practical
matter okay okay way we need to keep the
momentum going to be my view to the best
that we can given the constraints of the
law um so let's take number 17 then will
somebody move that we approve that thank
you ran seconded by Barry um is there
any further discussion of that point um
if not all those in favor say I
those
against carried thank
you so we're in
your okay so um I'll move back up then
to recommendation two so you'll recall
um that at the October council meeting
you confirmed the
majority of the budget directions and
those have been taken and have been
moved through into the asset and
activity plans and the financial impact
statements um following the workshop on
the 7th of December a number of matters
were discussed um and these are provided
now um for your consideration and
Direction um so do you want me to go
through them or I know some counselors
were not present at the workshop is that
helpful yeah no absolutely and I think
that there are although we traversed all
of those items at the workshop of course
there were no decision made respect to
those we just talked about them and
there was I think there was various
views amongst counselors so I think it
is appropriate to go back um and we will
have to take each those items
individually I think in terms of
agreeing or disagreeing with the the
point um I suspect that's going to take
up a fair proportion of the time but I
think we need to do it that way so let's
work through the those items starting
with a okay so the first item is a
capital expenditure item um that um was
simply missed from the earlier stage in
the earlier budget process so that's an
apology from our team that it just
didn't come up to you at the right point
so that's $1 million of capital
expenditure next financial year for
changing room improvements that's unisex
toilets and changing rooms at Splash
Palace and that's in response to um
identified need um in terms of the
changing rooms um not being large enough
to meet all the needs of the community
um and so hence this
recommendation thank you um Grant yeah
how how has the $1 million been arrived
at um so that has been arrived at with
the property team I'm not sure Aaron if
you have any more specifics that you
wish to
share
the the number that's been put in there
was arrived at through the work that the
pmo have done in collaboration with RCP
as the advisers on Building Maintenance
and deferred maintenance for the
building but it's Capital exp isn't it
not not M for the changing sheet it's a
split 70% capitals 30% Opex which is is
an estimate it really depends on how the
building holds together
any other questions on that
item I I must admit taking the
implication of Grant's question it does
seem an extraordinary large amount of
money and it's hard to imagine that's
the cheapest way of providing you know
small number of toilet Alex um may I
suggest um chair that we continue going
through the rest of the list because
we've already had you know like many of
these discussions before in the
workshops and this one has sort of just
been sprung on us so it will allow
everybody some time to percolate as to
what that could look like while we
continue we did discuss it watch but not
everybody was here M um just for some
clarity on the changing room um it is
it's extending outside of its current
footprint and that's hence why you have
the the dollar figure attached to it
because as it currently stands um it's
not with it reconfiguration just within
the site you actually need to extend um
out onto the uh North Boundary slightly
um to create the capacity to be able to
have those changing rooms within there
so and and6 toilets so so if I ask the
question another way Are the officers
comfortable that's a robust number for
that Capital
project it's it's an indication of I you
have I have to be honest at the moment
you go with a project at the stage it is
an estimate that has come through um
that stage it's still in your plus and
minus perspective because they need to
do the detailed design component yeah um
but it is a rough estimate of what it
would cost I would be happy to pick up
um Alex's suggestion that we um keep
that one to a little bit later in the
discussion
um I think what we'll find is as we go
through these that some of them we can
uh approve very quickly and easily and
there'll be other ones that are a little
bit more contentious and it may be
better that we keep those to the end and
talk about those then um actually rangy
had his
qu uh look to me this's quite simple
staff have put forward a million dollar
budget they've obviously thought about
it they wouldn't put it here they
wouldn't they haven't got a r roulette
wheel they spin around so I have full
confidence that the million dollars is
has um has absolute meaning and I don't
know why we're even talking about it
well we're talking somewhere we're
talking about because we still have to
agree disagree that that should be in
the budget it's not only a matter of
whether it's a million or 900,000 or 1.1
it's whether we approve it or
all Les Mr chair um could I concur with
Council CET that perhaps we should go
through b to G and then come back to
whether or not we can agree to all of
them or whether we're then going to pick
out any of them it just seems it would
move it forward a bit more is one of the
counselors who wasn't the year I've done
a bit of looking into the um changing
room situation and I consider the
million dollars to be a reasonable
opposition but let's let's work through
the others and then see if everybody's
in agreement that we can so let's do
that so ran and
B so B is put forward um following the
direction from Council to um the
executive leadership team to look for
ways in which we may make savings um
this was one of the areas identified um
the pilot actually completed in between
the first report and the second so we
now are confident we can deliver that
program for $100,000
less so how does so
questions anybody have any questions
ring now this makes absolute sense it
was really a trial when we approved this
way back the 300 they've obviously tried
it found they can do it for 200 makes
sense
okay so sounds as so that's going to get
the nod
c three around again is um that further
work was able to be done as those
projects that relate to project 1225
come further to completion those
operational budgets for maintenance have
been able to be completed with um
greater accuracy obviously reflecting
that those buildings are new and so
maintenance costs across the first 10
years that is a combined figure not an
annual figure to be really clear it's a
combined figure across those three
facilities 10 years saving of $850,000
thank you any questions on
that comments Okay
C we done see d d is um around the
direction that Council had had an in
discussion at that Workshop that the um
General consens was was that 150,000 was
the appropriate amount for a pump track
the earlier paper council did confirm
funding at
250,000 um is the advice of officers
that external funding will need to be
sought for the um project to proceed um
so hence bringing this recommendation
back to you to adjust that figure down
as
required let me ask I I thought that the
last pump track that we did 120,000
didn't it that the case and just wonder
why this one is a lot more
expensive just a couple of things to you
Mr chair um noting this is 26 20 2026
2027 um so there is there's some
discussion around that through the the
team that I've heard um and I would say
that it's not rather than just noting
that external funding will required it
should be subject to external funding
because it won't be able to be achieved
If It Isn't So it's going to be subject
to external funding at that price so we
we will put in the budget in
150,000 and
the expectation is not quite the right
word and hope that actually that the job
can be done for that and somewhat but if
it cannot then we're going to rely on
external funding or else we're going to
have to cut cloth to suit cut suit to
suit the cloth yeah okay thank you so
we' got 150 I think that's the where we
probably are okay um e is an interesting
one item e is um again there's a timing
issue in terms of this work needing to
be done for the ltp ahead of the
detailed paper that the committee will
receive on this project specifically so
the council had given direction for
asking what would need to be done to
make this building um safe to be being
used over the short term noting the
indication that potentially in the
medium term an alternative location for
council's administration building might
be found so um this is providing
information around the remaining 15.4
million Capital that would be spent
between 2024 and 25 and 2028 and 29 this
is as for deferred maintenance Works
deferred Building Life systems heating
ventilation cooling lighting electrical
and fire and ongoing project costs to
enable this building to be safely
occupied for the first five years of the
long-term plan questions for
Rihanna good yeah is it's it's a lot of
money obviously
um are we CH putting good M money out
the beard I suppose is what I'm trying
to factor into my
head um
yeah it's it's a lot of
money not saying the work doesn't need
done but we we've started a process of
looking alternative options haven't we
so do we you know do we are we spending
money to us as my concern
probably I think I'll just speak briefly
to the process and then pass it to the
GM of infrastructure um it's important
to make an allocation in the budget at
this point in order for the rating model
to be finished and audit to start we are
recognizing though that this is coming
ahead of the detailed paper that you
will get um it can be changed through
the audit process so I'll pass to you
Erin I think the first thing I'd say is
we we won't be making any efforts to try
to spend that money often we will try to
expend our money but this is one where
we won't be um attempting proactively to
spend the money I think the key pieces
to ranna's point we're still working
through that process around what our
future looks like for our building um
what we do know though is that
regardless of whether it's a
refurbishment of this building another
building that we build just for us
whether we go into another building with
another partner um either way that $ 154
million is going to be the absolute bare
minimum amount that we'll need um in
that first 10 years so I think teran's
point it would be remiss of us if we
didn't have um a a figure of at least
that in the long-term plan um to be able
to give us some position around setting
rates so sorry oh I'm sorry do yeah well
just
so if I think I heard you right there so
it may be that if things progress on an
alternative option that money set a SW
and would then just sit within another
bucket in effect that that's right we we
do have an allocation to have to spend
money to keep the lights on in this
building um and we'll have to spend what
it takes to do that um but in terms of
you know we're not looking to
proactively be prettying up this
building um we would absolutely be
looking to potentially move this money
to a future project the moment we decide
what that project is and what the start
expend of that would be 24 25 so we're
12 months away from that is that what
how I read the numbers that's right yeah
thank you
Ry um so reading this
literally um is says the
15.4 is
to allow us to safely occupy the
building for the first 5 years of the lp
ltp so after 5 years um what do we do
then because obviously we're back in the
same position we are now that's the way
I read it literally we're back where we
are today so in 5 years time are we
going to be sitting here or whoever is
around the table what are we going to do
now cuz obviously it's no longer safe
again or it's otherwise it should say
for the next 10 years or whatever or
something it says 5 years
so that's the B I'm bit confused about
am I reading it literally right I think
the discussion were you at the workshop
on the 7th of uh
December I don't remember but I I think
the discussion there was that we would
um what it would if we were to decide
that we were going to build another
building let's just suppose then by the
time we got all necessary approvals and
consents and we actually built the thing
it would probably be a period of 5 years
so youve probably got 5 years in this
building anyway so that's where the
number five years came from shouldn't
you actually use the time period that
your actual um what you're doing will
last so if the air conditioning is going
to last 10 years when you say that and
if the other lighting is going to last
longer than 10 years wouldn't you
actually say that it just gives the
impression that we're doing a 5 year fix
and after that I mean that's why I read
it that's why I asked is it literally
saying what it says so if I I go Darren
um we'll go around the table and then we
can come back eron made the point I was
going to
raise Erin made the point I was going to
raise okay did you want to say something
around I was just going to speak to the
reasoning for the wording so that you
could um inform the discussion around
any adjustment um so putting this weding
together with Lee obviously with his
expertise in the pmo office it reflects
two things it reflects the years across
which the budget was allocated which was
a council direction that you wished to
understand what would be necessary to
keep this building operational while an
alternative was sought and secondarily
it signals that there may be further
work that would be necessary beyond that
point um should the choice be made to
then inhabit this building for longer um
there will be more detail that will come
through from the from the pmo in the
paper um but it was speaking very
directly to the direction that was given
to the team from Council as to what you
wish to receive now I'll just clarify
that to say that is not to assume either
that as councelor p and jurus said that
you would be um writing off Assets in
some way after 5 years that's not what
it's intended to suggest neither is it
intended to suggest that at the end of 5
years there would definitely be further
funding that would need to be spent um
it is quite specific to the direction
that was given by Council thank you
Leslie youa thanks Mr chair uh to some
extent ranan said what I was going to
say it seemed to me that it's put in for
very for a very specific fiveyear
Financial year period for the reason
specified within that time Council will
have come to to a conclusion about the
future of this building or any other
proposal that may be being worked on um
that doesn't include this building and
that anything that is spent in that
meantime um would be useful for the
future life of this building if it
was not to be a council occupied
building but it seems to me we have to
make the provision I think since the
time I have been on C
we have had a number of discussions
about the issues with this building as a
place for our staff to be housed and
indeed to some extent for our Council to
be housed um and there are basic
tasks
um put in quite clearly here that need
to be done and need to be done urgently
if we're going to occupy this building
for a longer period and we've had the
discussion about the first 5 years of
the long-term plan
realistically um being 5 years in which
we would not have a new building built
if the decision was made to go that way
just seems to me we need to make the
Practical we need to make the Practical
allocation if we're going to be
realistic about living in this building
for longer and asking our staff to live
them this building Grant did you have
another
comment a question no
oh wow I was just going to sort of
clarify ringy's question around
um you know
that if you if you spend your 50 million
you don't want to just spend it because
of the five years you know it's going to
have to have a longer view so is the
time
frame
right to extend it why we liting VI yeah
sorry R you were trying to get in
oh just to through you chair in response
to that question um I guess um what the
pmo is signaling is if you extend beyond
that point they will have further work
to do and there may well be further
budget that would be required and they
don't know that at this point but what
they can do give you is a fairly good
confidence on the 15.4 across the first
five years which is what they were
asked I I think I have if I can comment
I think I have
two um
issues with this I'm not going to debate
the 15.4 million I think that's you know
a number that's
obviously comes from arithmetic adding
up all the work it needs to be done to
the building but two comments the first
is that the more we spend in this
building the harder it's going to be to
make a choice to go somewhere else so if
we invest $15 million in this building
so that the additional cost that's
required to make make it long term sa us
another 10 million just for argument
sake that that was a far more likely
decision to be taken than deciding to
you know build a completely new building
so it makes the more we spend the harder
it becomes to decide to do something
else the second comment I would make was
is that we
are hopefully going to be in a position
within the course of the next financial
year
to have a preference
for what we want to do I think I'm
looking at I say this because Le is not
here that that we would have say by the
end of by the end of next financial year
we would have looked at the options know
whether we're likely to have any anybody
want to join us in those those buildings
and we would have decided maybe in a
location and got somewh so I I would
hope that by the end of next financial
year we'd be that
point that that would bring me a point
saying that in the next financial year
until that decision is
taken that we should minimize the spend
in 20 2024
2025 and not make any commitments which
are the larger items during that period
so I know for example if we decide to um
change out the windows do the work
necessary in the windows that is a very
large part of that 15.4 million right so
so so maybe you would park that project
until the end of next financial year
till you had a a better idea which way
you want to go so that um if I look at a
distribution of the 15.4 my own view
would be that over 5 years that it may
be a little bit of hocky stick rather
than a straight line hocky stick in the
sense that it's a little bit backhanded
in years 35 make you want to say
something through yourself cheer um what
I'd like to highlight and and you're
quite right about it um the timing in
relation to some of this is pushed to L
in the period um the the work that
you're talking about here is to allow us
to continue to occupy um the building
during that time frame um and some of
the cases should that work not be
engaged there'll be a larger operating
cost Associated to not being in the
building um just want to highlight that
because the things that we're talking
about are to keep staff in the building
um and and that's the only cost that's
been included in that 15.4 is to get us
through that um 5e period from that
perspective um yes when you do those
replacement costs there is a longer life
to those assets but you can't patch
we're at the stage it's not patch
anymore we actually have to do the work
to actually replace those things and
that comes out of cost so it's it's not
strictly an investment uh from that
perspective CU you're only trying to
limp it through for a life
but now it's got to Stage it's quite a
high cost to limp it through for that
particular time frame um we um actively
looking at it to go what what do we have
to do as opposed to what do you want to
do it's it's more now what do we have to
do to get it through to that 5 years and
that's the indication that we're put in
there to get through that period this is
what we're indicating we believe we're
going to need to spend to get to that
time frame um which is within that time
frame we will hopefully have a decision
in relation to what is that next stage
and also hopefully have worked on an
action plan to say at the end of the 5
years we're not in the building from
that perspective um or we're in a
renovated building um so it's kind of
saying that that is a cost that to get
us to that point if we can spend less um
we would quite openly try and do that
but um so what about the the I mean I
don't know how it's spread through
through the the 5year period at the
moment um I don't know if it's straight
line but the um how about the notion of
avoiding any large projects during the
first year until we make the decision
well that's what the time frame says
though doesn't it because I think it
affect with the 2425 you're not doing
anything for the first next year there's
very little in 20 2425 and 25 26 most of
it is in the the later periods but um
there is a small portion in those
periods well we got to keep the show on
the road so I mean you know but I I I
just think that if we were decide say
next year to replace the windows I know
that what you told me it's a large very
large amount of money just for the
scaffolding and then you know so I think
about half the total cost is the windows
and and once you once you fire a start
gun in that project you don't want to
stop it half through so it's a you know
that's the sort of thing I would see you
back end that's where the hockey stick
comes
yeah that's great okay so and any other
questions on that is on that matter um
oh two
Alex look I think when I was going to
speak on it um everybody else sort of
jumped in and said what I was going to
say but really just wanted to reinforce
that we have health and safety
obligations to employees not necessarily
us ourselves but as Governors but
through our CE uh and they're really
indicating to us that literally just to
keep the lights on this is what we have
to do yeah um the fact that so that the
impact that it would have on the
community if we actually had to close
the the front doors downstairs would be
pretty catastrophic or even just have to
relocate like it's I think it's it's
pretty critical at the moment that we
just get on and do it thanks for that
Alex Alex is qu P 5 do you I don't I do
realize I do do realize I've got five
minutes but I think I can
squee yeah look it's we were told by the
pmo that to do the whole building up TIY
boo 26
23 million um
so if the master if our big ultimate
goal of having this shared new building
fails is the
15.4 going to be well spent in regards
to jumping in with the
26.2 or to get to that
26.2 stage is it going to cost us 30 in
the end you know like just by doing this
interim stuff is it going to catch us
out because obviously it's a you're
actually rolling the dice here I agree
and the biggest issue around that R is
I'm certain you know that if you project
package the whole thing then you'll get
a much more elegant correct construction
process it will be cheaper than if
you're doing dribs and dabs you know a
non ideal stage so so I'm I'm not
supporting this at all so I'm just
declaring that now you're not supporting
at all the 15.4 no cuz I don't think
it's been thought through
I am that's my own view you to vote
lesle I just want to say it focuses our
minds on making the
decision say any more that I think I
think we we should remember that this is
basically a a bookmark in the long-term
plan um we may well end up doing
something different if we make a
different decision with respect to a
different you know we build something
new for example are we Partners who you
know want to provide some alternative
for us so it's but to put something in
the long-term plan which just say this
is we believe is we must if we stay in
this building for the next 5 years we're
going to have to spend this amount
doesn't mean we actually spend it and I
and I think given that we um two things
given that we have not quite a time out
but very little spending in the first
couple of years and given within the
first couple of years we will then
decide um whether we are going to go to
another building or whatever you know
for me personally it makes it a little
bit easier to make that easier to make a
you know is actually quite a tough
decision but anyway
we'll oh I was just actually going to
about to say what you just said to sorry
um oh yeah yes so no totally agree with
what you said I mean it to have it there
as as the safety net and really for our
staff you know sou to make sure that the
lights stay on for years at least but
the thing is you may not spend it I
think or you may actually have another
decision by then I think another issue
is that I'm certain that staff including
M are
being forbearing in the sense that they
are putting up with an unsatisfactory
situation and and the expectation that
things are going to get better fairly
soon as we spend out money if if staff
would confront the situation that there
was nothing in the long-term plan and
that nothing was going to be done with
this building and because that would be
the implication to put nothing in the
longterm plan if that was the case then
I think we would get resignations and we
would you know not only that but we
would have senen your staff include
Michel you know really having post for
thought about whe it can go in the way
us that be right
Michael just to finish off I'm just
thinking that you're all sort of talking
about the same thing to be fear the the
wording here pretty much says what Ry
saying so why not to add a couple of
words in there say that if maybe you
know like a just a couple of words to
change it so that it does read more like
this is the possibility that maybe spent
if you know blah blah blah as opposed to
you're doing it just change the wording
a little bit I think it be say what you
say yeah yeah I I think the wording I
would maybe add and it comes to the same
thing actually is to just be explicit
the very little of
that a a small proportion of that money
would be spent in the first two years
until a decision was maybe spent between
blah blah
blah may be in
there I don't
know wouldn't we be in a position or
shouldn't we be aiming to be in a
position around if there's an
alternative it's explored in the next 12
months and we're pretty you know firm on
that's the the preferred option I don't
think we want to be waiting for 2 years
for that we either need to know that
there is another option or there isn't
and get on with it yeah but whether it's
one year or two years
we we we've got a firm up in a longterm
plan in the next month or two and if we
put nothing in the longterm plan it
becomes very difficult to actually spend
our money does it if we if we think that
we have
to uh through soft Cher um I'll probably
go back to Ron's time timetable in
relation to um this going through the
consultation audit process this is the
stage where you're approving what goes
forward to audit for review um to go
into your consultation document you
still have a decision point should
anything change between now and that
point which is if you have new
information at the table which we
haven't got at this stage that would
change the direction in relation to that
and you might have other options then
you would be able to put that forward
into that consultation we need to take
that through with audit but that would
be one of the proposals and also you've
got that other option which is something
happens during the consultation process
before we get to June and you have a
final um option available at that stage
then you can put that through into the
final
documentation um but we don't have
anything in that shape or form at this
stage to be able to put into any of the
documents uh we so therefore what we
have to put in as what as that holding
component to get us through to that
point and that's what needs to be into
our original uh initial consultation
component that's what we're seeking um
as part of e um we would hope that we
might have something further by the time
we get through that process um to take
to the community or um as part of the
deliberations process but I say we're
not in that stage at this point Thank
you Patricia you're looking to see
something all the microphone very um
I've just check the budget the bulk of
that 15.4 is actually in years three and
four of the long-term plan so it is
quite light in year one and two um could
we UPS then I mean I think that's the
answer so could could we perhaps add to
that paragraph a note that um very L of
money I don't know if very L is the
right what was the best word the the
bulk of that spending will be years 3
to5 that is what the budget already has
in it so it has the has 14 over 14
million of that I'm just counselors
including me Comfort that there is
actually that as because that's we're
approving we just put as per budget yeah
if if it if it's going to satisfy
councilors to have those few words in
there it could be as simple as what
councel der's just just suggested as per
as per budget
see okay so we'll do some word smithing
on that when actually approving it at
this stage coming back to do that so we
can move on while that thinking is going
on so ran and the L approach to lale yes
so um Council has discussed through
various committees different portions of
potential land um that could be
considered for disposal or
optimization um we're forecasting a
conservative amount within the budget um
just two points to note the first is
that
um these numbers will need to be
reviewed by a valuer and that may change
them um and that will be completed ahead
of the long-term plan being adopted
and the second point is just to note
that these estimates have been included
for the purposes of budgeting it does
not preempt or preclude the
decisionmaking process that Council will
make for each of these Parcels of land
individually it is a composite
forecast um and should not be taken as
having made Council made determination
to actually sell it is a
forecasting element thank you
D so I have
an issue with this and that it's it's
it's vague enough that you can't really
identify what blocks of land are being
talked about and that's fine but the
thing is and amongst some of those that
are being considered uh constraints
around how the money can be used so for
us to be able to say and if that it'll
be used to reduce
borrowings is not
Kosher in some cases it might not
R yeah so may become available but it's
use it whereas there you're determining
your
use you would you would propose changing
it to be used in accordance with the uh
requirements of I'm not quite sure of
the word you can propose but well it
depends on the block of land it doesn't
some of them unencumbered but some of
them may have um restrictions you need
to state of use in the long-term
plan so the reason it was included and
then Patricia may want to add more is to
State how it has been modeled to reduce
council's net debt position so could we
well could we then see um this reflects
or how it is modeled in the how it will
be modeled in the budget but recognizing
that there will be constraints who over
how the money is actually allocated oh
even if it's uh we add to reduce
borrowings where
permissible all right that covers it off
uh through yourself cheer I would
actually recommend you just uh remove
the words to be used to reduce borings
because it's um how it's actually used
as in accordance with the requirements
of each individual landsite and it um it
doesn't actually add or subtract in
relation to um the model how you model
it okay okay with
that thank any other questions on that
one so that's not we'll go to
G
so G relates to addition of a special
dividend from CHL um so this would be in
addition to the um signaled request
through the letter of expectation of the
5.2 million which is the core dividend
this would be a special dividend 4
million a year across 10 years of the
long-term plan um and
um would be included in an amendment to
the letter of expectation
questions of
Rihanna
so sorry
um so you that's modeled in the budget
obviously that's why it's 4 years over
years um that was the direction from the
workshop as I understand it it's 4 over
10 to be held on term deposit to allow
that Revenue generation that we need for
to meet the benchmarks
interesting okay ground yeah so how
would that implicate the letter of
intent to
H we would give them an update yeah
right but they are they are aware of the
direction I mean this reflects the
intention that's already been signaled
that we look at the
portfolio and we can and and it and
budget I mean we may do different things
with that money when we receive it but
something's going to be assumed for H
plan and purposes yeah so this is the
approach that's been taken for plan and
purposes well that's actually what we
end up doing I think is a you know I
think becomes a matter of debate m is
that fair we're not tied
by um through through self chair this is
giving an indication through to the
holding company as part of the long-term
plan process that that's what we would
be um anticipating um they would um we
would place on them to try and Achieve
over the the 10 years um what we did
indicate to uh during the workshop was
if we received all of that in the in a
one lump from our perspective in um one
year does not meet our requirements in
um in relation to revenue over the 10
years um so we it's counterintuitive to
our actual um Revenue splits that we
need to achieve from a council um and
it's seen as better to hold the invest
investment and get the return on an
annual
basis still same outcome for us in same
Revenue so so just another question CH
so should it be additional dividend as
opposed to special
dividend additional dividend of of 4
million over 10
years because that thinking through that
um it may be that they you know through
optimization of portfolio they can
achieve additional increase in dividend
without a special dividend and special
dividend is
different it suggest it's more one off
than
Exel re reoccurring income um I think
that's probably a mute point for the the
the wording whether it's a special
dividend they recognized that it would
be additional on top of the 5.1 and
that's what we're trying to get through
we're just calling it a special dividend
so that it differentiates it from their
standard dividend to us which has
already been signal terms of public
consultation it could be interpreted as
okay why is it different to an increase
in dividend as opposed to special
because special div have different
connotations we can probably work
through that at consultation um it
wasn't so I I think I mean I understand
what it means and you understand to
Grant it's more a matter of is it open
to misinterpretation yeah that's right
yeah that's what and I think that comes
to rather than you know what we're
approving today I don't think it's
easily misinterpreted but but what
actually goes out and consultation
document maybe needs to be you know the
wording needs to be crafted it may end
up with the same wording but we just
need to you know question you know what
the Worden should be is that
yeah so um that brings us to the end of
the sorry points to R oh just a quick
question on G sorry if we if we don't go
ahead with that that totally
derails say item nine you know I mean we
can't this is all what we carry on to
next is based on us agreeing to G is
that
correct that 4 million per year over 10
years it means that the budget would be
based on that presumption yeah it is but
if you look at that if you look at every
Point 8G above that it's exactly the
same we may not we may end up not doing
it we is is especially a special one I
see significant amount of
money if that was not agreed that would
have we we couldn't actually agree nine
because it would be a very different
number as a
result sorry I think the other thing
that I would say in that though too is
that we have already included in letter
of expectation wording that kind of up
to it's not like we in a um sry Leslie
you were going to say something I was
just going to say it might help if G
just had the words added to it after
term deposit to reduce the net debt
position because that's what we're
talking
about and that's what the further
information already says so why not just
add those words it makes it perfectly
obvious that's the effect I think it
does clarify it to ad those words it's
not point it's not really the point that
rangy was making but I think that the
would be helpful words R's point is what
if it doesn't happen well what I'm
saying is that actually does
clarify oh okay R's point to some extent
because it makes it perfectly obvious
we're talking about reducing the net Deb
position as part of a financial strategy
which is what nine is about so actually
putting those words quite openly in G
just spells it
out we don't we don't pass G yes we're
looking at we're relooking at
nine so we go back then to I think the
issue we've done quite a amount of work
on most of them if not all of them
um point a I think was the one which
was change mind the one where Alex
suggested that we leave to the end and
she's no longer here
um that one is a kind of yes or no
not rather than there's not a lot of
fidling with the the whats in that
one so R you want to say something yeah
I just say like it's an obvious yes you
just we don't have the staff here or the
information to wle whether it could be
850 or whatever I I don't think it's I
don't think it's a matter of exact
amount of money I think it's more
whether we see that as a a project that
we'd want given that we haven't actually
seen it before I I say yes we need to do
it otherwise it wouldn't be here I have
total faith in staff that is here for
reason can I just ask um just by show
hands who agrees that project should be
done yeah agrees agrees yeah okay so
that's pretty clear so in that case I
think we um can probably take all of
those items excepting Ry that I know
that there's one that you would wish to
vote against which is this building I
think wasn't it
um but we can take all of them and you
can and you know vot against no okay I'm
happy to move um one and two of the
recommendations just to get us moving
see that again I'm happy to move one and
two of the
recommendations right you mean one and
two not the NB receiving the report and
agreeing right to a to G okay okay so
given the mod the Amendments we've made
given the modifications to wordings that
we have already um discussed and
assuming that that's part of the um part
of the motion is there somebody who
second that we approve those thanks Dar
um all those in favor I those
against carried thank
you so that takes us through to number
three
three I'm happy to move 3
a right am I writing thinking am I right
in thinking um that these are options
that we go to public with without making
a recommendation about one or other
correct the last one is purely for the
public to decide tell us do they
prefer um a blue bin or not a blue bin
okay it's a consultation thing that's
right the point I was making is that the
council is not recommending one of the
other we just put the two equal options
well we see I need the refer preferred
option I need a preferred option for
both three and four what the preferred
option does is it signals to the
community the option council is leaning
towards and it is the one that is
included in the budget um the preferred
option is the preferred option is
included in the budget so you have
already had various discussions around
the glass bins and you have already
signaled that your preferred option is
the blue bin which is why I've taken the
liberty of putting that wording into to
there um the two options that have been
are presented for you had not been
costed up previously um so they're now
presented here option one to introduce a
new fortnightly glass bin collection
Services estimated to be a
0.84% rates increase that would be a
level of service increase it does
require obviously investment in the bins
themselves it requires investment in the
truck to collect the bins and it
requires operational increase option two
if you don't introduce the glass bins
and the offices as you'll see in the
paper are signaling that they expect the
contractor to withdraw services in 2025
so if if you went for preferred option
two for example the budget would remain
unchanged for year one but then from
year two onwards um the change would be
implemented um essentially the
community's options would be either to
not cycle glass and put it into the red
bins and therefore the team have
forecast the operational increases
required through the extra weight of
collecting all that glass um or bottle
Banks all right so just to be clear
which have we assumed in the um
calculations that we've done in terms of
rates so far option one is in the budget
at present right so um can I ask rangy
and this is your area more than anybody
else's do you wish to propose option one
is that your yeah I think that's the
option as long as I'm of the
understanding that we've got the bins
we've got the collection
service but the end
user of the glass or where it ends
up what what happens then is that what
we were had the presentation on about
the person turning it into a fine
substrate or or because obviously that
must have been costed as well to do
84 you've got to have a it's got to go
somewhere it's it's a really good point
counselor so through you chair in the
body of the report is more detail in
terms of the wording that at this point
we intend to provide to the
community um there is an estimate of the
current amount of glass that we believe
is
reused and then there is a forecast on
the amount of glass that we believe has
potential to be reused under or option
one so that would be an increase from
about 60 to 70% at the moment to
potentially 90% it does rely on there
being a contractor to be available to
actually use that glass um and that
obviously is something that will um is
subject to economic forces just like the
issue of the first contractor not being
able to receive glass um if that came to
a situation that there was no New
Zealand market for the glass it would
need to be
offsh I'm saying we have been told and
we've had a presentation to Council of
of an intended user yeah yeah we any
other questions
of just with the glass McGregor
conqu willing to take the glass yeah
that's so we are asked to confirm that
the following consultation options and
particularly noting the option one is a
preferred option which Ry has spoken to
um will somebody move
that okay we take bar a second there um
all those in favor say I I against
carried thank you number four so number
four speaks to the issue of the elderly
person's housing activity that's been
discussed at a number of points through
the year um I will um just speak to the
reason for the changing in the wording
on option one um so as I mentioned
earlier the rating model has is the last
part to be completed that rating model
is quite complex so there is potentially
flux in that
0.5%
um the exact amount of the rates
increase will depend on the
repayment profile that's put in place
for the capital and the interest
that may be appropriate to profile that
differently to some other Capital within
the program given the nature of the
activity so that is the part that's
still to be
finalized um so just to signal that this
is very likely to change slightly
through the audit process at present
it's modeled at 0.3 in year 1 and then
it declines slowly over time so it's
like 0.3 in year two Etc we are
expecting that to come down a certain
amount but there will the important part
to take away is that this is on top of
the rates increase in the
recommendation um nine earlier down so
the question that you asked earlier
about which option was in for glass at
present option two is what is in the
budget but we are know obviously it is I
I do not know what council's preferred
option is I need to understand that from
you and we will change the budget as
required there will be a rates increase
for option one as we've signaled um we
expect it to be 0.5 or
less okay questions of
Rihanna Rihanna need um I'll ask
question the the oh sorry you got Grant
yeah trying to work yet
so the rates increase of
.5% on the basis of the capital of 7
million so that's am ization is the cost
of the rates the rates increases
relation to the amortization of the loan
to fund the repayment of the loan and
the interest cost on that what's
theorization term uh we've done it over
years so that's what yeah have the
useful off isn't
it I think I think when Council
discussed
this Council and Workshop we discussed
this I think one of the issues that was
mentioned was that while current policy
is to have the current tenants fund any
work gone forward that there is nothing
comes from General rates for me a point
that was made that is important is the
fact that those current tenants don't
actually benefit our
all from the building of it's the
current it's a generation which is
younger that benefits from it in other
words a general rate Pair by large so to
me that's
the that's the argument that you know
it's got some force with
me um the other issue was if there is
nothing in the ltp there is no capital
on the ltp then if there were an
opportunity to apply to government for
funding and if there was any need to
match fund it would not be possible to
um have any bucket to take money from to
help Michael was was that the case or
have I got that wrong no through
yourself to that is correct if there's
no funding available for
um for capital investment then we
wouldn't be in a position to um match
Fund in relation to that um noting that
you would also be increasing that number
by the value of the land and the
buildings that you would um put into the
um overall number so if there was an
opportunity to get money for
50 homes or something like that which
might be you know $25
million it could be they even having put
in money for infrastructure and for um
and the value of the land there may be
some shortfall and thinking was one of
the thinkings were that if there was a
approved amount of money like this $7
million that might 7 million might guess
25 I that was the part of the logic
wasn't it Lesley thanks Mr Cher I
suppose this one I I thought was an
important one to
put the propositions or the options to
the public for that feedback until now
the feedback has had generally
been public of in very happy that we're
in housing and want us to stay in
housing for elderly but have said up
rates we now need to know
what is the appetite now from the public
considering the climate for housing the
known need um the the ongoing population
needs of theable population all those
things we put in the longterm plan what
is the appetite for actually getting the
indication now is has the public theago
now changed where we'll get the feedback
that says yes put in
some ICC capital funding because it's
really important for the future of
this and I think the time has come for
us to ask that question if we're going
to be serious
about our units we know that there is a
large number of them built in the
50s that need replac pretty soon so
let's ask the question thank
you
yeah um I wonder if this is an
opportunity for us
to um look at where we will commit to
this if the government equally commits
to it you know and we know very well
that you know the the tax share between
local government and national government
is
inadequate this to me is no different to
um how we fund um emergency housing
which we don't we expect the government
to do it and they don't do a very good
job so you know why why are we putting
this burden additional burden on rate
payers when it's really a government
it's part of a government proposal
either they they fund it themselves
directly from central government and
from tax pool or they share more equally
tax so Grant are you suggesting we could
reframe option one to refer
to a a
j i mean I suppose one of the negatives
on that is if you include it in there
then you guar the government would
expect us to you know put in 7 million
whereas at the moment is written in a
way that that isn't necessarily how
would be used at the moment is put in is
to support the building of an extra four
units well effectively it's an extra
effectively it's four Replacements plus
four new ones so it's eight in total so
million eight that's
expensive so what you're saying Grant I
think is that it should
be written in a way that
it's um a requirement that there some
contribution any investment made by rate
payers is equally matched by central
government so it's a big I know it's a
big ask but it Point
reality the four and four is slightly
incorrect it's actually replacing units
so that we end up by the end
worth 220 so that is recognizing that
how we have modeled it is that 7 million
is used to
replace um the oldest units first but
trying to increase the number of units
on those sites so that we by the time we
get to the end we've got
220 so that's what the the general
modeling is um I would as has been
suggested if there was Government
funding at does mean we have got already
got some Capital funding sitting in our
long-term plan that we could participate
in without it we would be in a much more
difficult position should something come
along it's it seems like one of those
issues where we could have we could have
because we've got the time for the
finalize wording this could be another
one of those where we could adjust the
option
wording if we get an indication in the
next 6 months that the government might
very well be looking at assisting
councils with
building um new housing that would be an
interesting point at which to change
these
options because clearly and I've said
this before but clear clearly you can
expect the existing elderly tenants to
fund the next generation of increased
number of houses that was you know
completely contrary to any kind of logic
sorry yeah I was just going to say um
should we perhaps have a third option in
there and look at the possibility of
should we actually be involved in this
because to be fair even with the number
we've got we're only looking after a
very small number of our local community
the entire Community is funding it now
I'm not saying it's something that is a
bad thing it's a good thing but it is
actually as Grant said it's it's a
central government issue really as
opposed to local government so in fact
should we have an option there to see if
people would like us to actually leave
the space and move out of
it have a third option and have homeless
no I'm sorry I wouldn't agree with it so
ran um so to those two um previous
questions I've um through you chair I
speak to council Arnold's suggestion
first um council did give direction back
in May that you wish to stay in the
elderly person's housing activity and
wished options prepared on that basis so
you could rev that decision now but it
would put us in a really difficult
position in terms of finalizing options
ahead of consultation it would be
extremely difficult
um because there's a whole like when you
change and you remove yourself out of an
activity that's a whole another process
and it's complex um so I would say we
are really too late to do that in a
robust way um speaking to the point
around saying we would only proceed if
we got much government
funding um if the audit process proceeds
as it normally does we would not be able
to proceed with that audit requires us
to fund what we have in the plan where
we note we are expecting external
funding we would have to provide
evidence as to what we believe that
would be applied too and note that we
would underwrite it anyway um it is
these are the consultation options um to
council soapa Point around the wording I
think that it would be appropriate to
put some wording in the um supplementary
information noting that Council you know
is going to take the feedback of the
community and um take this into account
when it makes this final decisions
ultimately when you make the final
decision you can shift and change based
on new information
that happened last long-term plan for
example we consulted on two Museum
options and by the time it got to the
decision making actually Council said we
do want to look at a new building so
that is a possible in appropriate I
think that is an important point isn't
it this is putting a marker in the
budget um Place hold in the budget for
an amount of money um before that money
can be spent a paper would have to come
back to count wouldn't it so you know at
that point Grant you get the I mean just
put money in you know I mean it might
the paper of dat come back saying we
want to build four houses or whatever
and it could be that Council would
support or not support ises that case
and we would also have the community
consultation giving us the community's
up to-date
views three self I just want to
highlight I've had the number four baned
a lot and you see the four on there it's
actually um 20 new houses with 16 being
decommissioned that's what you get four
out of um hence if you do the sums then
you end up with a very expensive house
but um actually it's it's 20 new um and
16 shifting into those new houses only
four
new okay that's an important point so
you going to go to the voter which
option uh I think that's preferred
option I think that's probably look I
think the third option I mean we could
if you want Alan but I'm pretty sure
that it's not going to get up because we
talked we debated it last time it was
was just a yeah I I know that that's
your view out there so um I will put
hands up those who would support option
one it's the preferred option H as a
preferred option as a preferred option
yeah okay so look I think the majority
would support option one so I think in
that case up BEC comes a preferred
option a second okay so we'll do that at
this stage then somebody we conflicted
because we're getting older are we
conflicted because I'm getting older
exactly so I'm taking it you're moving
Ry that we I don't mean moving L house I
are you moving that we have option A is
the preferred option correct yeah thank
you second thanks bar two of the oldest
people in the room that's highly
surprising I'll if it's
requ okay all those in favor say I
against carried thank you come on um
number five we're moving four all
together because the two options are
then move as consultation so we need to
now move four together okay so I'll move
I'll move forward I'll second thank you
those in favor say I I I against carried
number five move hold on it not Council
will receive fees and charges for
adoption by Council and okay so you'll
move it thank you is there a second
thanks Lesley all those is it Pap say I
I against carried um number
six okay confirm the following changes
can be made to the financial assumptions
so has Council seen those before or
these I don't recall these ones did we
Workshop those we our Workshop yeah so
um if I can just um just really briefly
speak to five just to note that there
are increases in the fees and charges in
line with the rates increase and with
cost increases so any changes that you
make in January to significant Revenue
lines could impact the budget just to
flag that but that will be brought back
in detail in January on number six these
are the financial assumptions that you
have received I think um Deputy Mayor
you made a we joke at the time that I
might have sent the paper to every
committee that I could find which I did
did did indeed do so risk and insurance
infrastructure community wellbeing and
Council have all received the
assumptions and that just reflects how
important they are um which Andrew has
spoken about many times from a risk
management point of view as well as a
budgeting point of view so these are the
adjustments to the financial assumptions
um they just note the changes in the um
interest rates and inflation based on
new information becoming available they
are not massive changes but they are
small important changes that have big
flow through impact to the budgets um
rria would be able to speak more if you
want anything on the detail on a and b
um C just simply notes the point that
you've confirmed above that we will
include the land sales as a forecasting
assumption that's necessary for audit
and do the same thing so um it's really
just a tech technical adjustments to the
assumptions okay any questions of ran
and the those will somebody move that we
confirm those I'm
move pardon six and seven
I'll do six first you just confuse Meely
so um Grant and Ria I think moved and
seconded um is there any further
discussion all those in favor six say I
against
carried number seven note that further
changes are likely to be required to
assumptions a result of central
government regulatory
changes uh okay Leslie do you want to
move that one yeah I'll move because
it's
just is there a second or thanks R all
those in favor say I I against carried
number
eight so eight speaks to changes that
we're recommending to the financial
strategy as a result of further
Direction that's come from Council over
the last few meetings so the first deals
with the appropriate funding level for
depreciation so further work's been done
by the infrastructure and finance teams
to look into the detail in terms of the
depreciation profile for the different
asset classes um we signaled earlier
that this was would come through it has
quite a significant budgetary impact um
so it's provided there again Patricia
can answer any questions as necessary on
a um B deals with the proposed debt cap
which has been discussed by Council many
times through this year you'll recall
that present the debt cap is 150% of
Revenue um it also speaks to the um
issue the chief executive rais earlier
in terms of us um providing debt room
for
HL um it's the advice of officers that
it's appropriate to raise that debt crap
to 180% in those early years of the plan
and 200% in the um second four years
before declining again to 190% what that
will do is it deals appropriately with
the capital bow bow wave that we have
coming in terms of asset replacement in
our core
infrastructure um it enables on the
advice of officers Council to remain
prudent in terms of its approach to
managing debt whilst expanding it at the
rate needed to fund the capital program
it still allows that Headroom um for the
capital call from
HL um Point C relates to um the position
that we believed we would need to be in
in terms of providing all information
within the financial strategy for three
Waters in and out so there's a change in
the proposed debt cap that you can see
should three Waters be out the debt cap
would need to be higher for two years
but then would remain the same um so it
really just shows that inago city
council is in quite a unique position in
terms of being able to manage that debt
head room for its three Waters program
um D is about the adjustment that we're
recommending to the rates increase limit
Benchmark um it was at 6% within the
assumptions we're recommending it
increase to seven that is just to just
for the likely rates increase as a
requirement of the program that Council
has now finalized
on point e just notes that we intend to
provide all the net debt positions and
benchmarks for both modeling options at
this point and that's dependent on the
final negotiations with
audit okay thank you questions to rihan
and those
if not will somebody move that we
confirm those changes to the financial
strategy thanks Dar second and Leslie um
is there any further discussion no not
if not I'll put the motion all those in
favor of confirming all of a to e say I
I I against carried thank
you um number
nine so number nine we'll need an
adjustment based on the decision
above so that would make the um rates
increase for 2425
95% Michelle if you wouldn't mind
putting the wording up to 99.5% and we
will come back to council as soon as the
rating model is finished with the final
figure right so what decision did we
take that pushed up half a percent the
housing the housing one as I prefer so
we have to put the prefer goes into the
budget model y okay thank
you
um any questions of ran on
that if not will somebody move thanks
Grant and seconded Barry um all those in
favor say I I
against carried takes us to number 10 so
you need to increase that so um number
10 11 12 and 13 are all providing you
um just a picture of where we will be in
terms of the financial position um with
three Waters so of that now 99.5%
increase in 2024 25 4.2% is to meet
three Waters costs and it will be
4 uh sorry it will be 5.3 to meet all
other Council activity costs okay um so
I'll deal with a monitor team though re
any questions of reing on that so we
have to adjust that to 9 .5% again 9.5
9.5
okay so again are there any questions on
that if not we'll somebody move that
well it's for noting that we note um
item 10 thanks lesli and seconded done
um any more discussion all those in
favor say I I against carried at number
11 so number 11 notes that on the basis
of the modeled budget council could will
need to expect to run an unbalanced
budget for the first four years before
returning to balance in 28 29 um that's
been um produced following direction
from Council that that would be a
satisfactory approach it does show a
plan to return to a balanced budget um
so it's the office advice it's
prudent okay any questions of ranan on
that
one and if not will somebody move that
we thanks Grant second and Ria
um any other discussion on that
point no okay all those in favor say I I
I against
carried number 12 number 12 is a
technical point is just noting that one
of the benchmarks the essential Services
Benchmark breaches only in one year in
year
8 or no yeah in year eight um simply due
to the timing of the capital program
what is that timing what what
what it's simply to do with where the
allocation of spend is within the
program yeah it's a it's a um Benchmark
that is depreciation over replacement
it's just it's just a the way the
depreciation is modeling at the moment
is there any could I ask on that and I
mean it's a technical breach and I'm
sure it's not the end of the world but
10 years out I don't think we know very
precisely what our Capital spend profile
is going to look like um how much of an
adjustment to the profile would it take
to actually eliminate that uh breach and
would it have other negative effects if
we did
so um haven't really tried to eliminate
the breach it was uh trying to get the
timing right on the rest of the program
was probably more important um we will
have a look to see whether we can't
eliminate it once we go 10 years we
don't know exactly what the spend
profile is going to be and if there is a
you know if there is a different spend
profile that results there not breaching
that would certainly may be sensible if
there's no other negative not on effect
you're going to comment Mel yeah true
your self cheer um I think the the key
component to versus there's some
strategic projects in relation to the um
three Waters aspects um in in that
particular period which means there's a
lot of work happening in those spaces
but they're not deemed in the essential
Services component they they're more
deemed in um strategic works it's kind
of a Nuance in relation to the work
spend so we're actually spending more on
that year in those areas then um but
it's not something from a benchmarks
point of view we can alter we can't
shift something from one category to the
other um but we are still spending um at
the height and level during that period
for those services so it is just a
categorization issue um is that why it's
Bri because we're spending more than we
here yes correct um so I don't think we
can change the modeling component of it
to make it work um fair enough I mean if
it was 10 bucks or something no but I
mean if it's couple million or something
it is it quite a significant breach um
and we have spent coule looking at it I
think we might have to get it AED more
than $10 that's the of view we might
need to get it AED can I can I just say
that that far out I'm not sure that we
should ask staff to look at the question
of the forecast breach any further
because the potential that far out is
that we have made a very significant
Capital decision about a new building
which in itself going to change the
potential Capital spend in those out
years so I'm not sure I'm not sure it's
worth asking St to look particularly at
this one at the moment when we know from
their discussions that we've probably
got another major Capital issue that's
it speaks the robustness
of leave it at that so we are asked not
that we if there's no other questions
will somebody move that we not that
thanks Grant and second Dria others in
favor say I against
carried um number
13 um so that's very self-explanatory
it's just confirming that two of the
other um important benchmarks will be
met through all 10 years of the plan
okay any other questions so Grant you
moving or you I'll move it I'll second
it you move and bar seconded all those
in favor say I I against carried cute
number 14 so 14 deals with um the
policies that are required to be updated
in line with the financial strategy um
so A and B must be updated every ltp um
the D changes to the um draft Revenue
financing policy are noted um within the
body of the report um essentially the
revenue and financing policy outlines
how we will fund um council's activities
is in line with the financial strategy
so it notes a change of the funding
source for operating expenses to include
borrowing um it notes um a change to um
the structure of um the funding for
activities to note the change of the
preferred option for housing so we will
adjust that now um we are just also
making some changes to the way that the
document um is worded to make it a
little bit easier um to use so changing
the um funding mechanism table for the
activities to include percentages which
will be more uh which will be easier
rather for managers to use to make sure
that when they set their fees and
charges it's in line with the revenue
Finance policy um and we are noting the
proceeds from asset sales as a forast um
for capital
expenditure um so essentially it's just
really enacting the decisions that
you've made earlier on through the
process I have a question on it ran um
on H
15a where we say there's no changes
recommended to these required policies
actually if you look at that policy it
says it's for
consultation so in other words it's
worded the front page is worded the is
the same as ad D and number
14 um so sorry are you talking about 15
a I'm talking about 15 a that's an error
so I need to work out why that's
happened we're not we don't need to
consult on the rates postponement and
remissions policy okay had you already
noticed that had you no but I am taking
note of it right now take my word for it
it does okay Alan I have to go to pardon
I have to leave okay then apologies yeah
thank
you okay so um number 14 um we'll take
all the same time I think has anybody
get any questions or noise of
Rihanna you move is there a second there
thanks Dan um are there any other is
there any other discussion of those and
if not um all those in favor say I I
against carried thank you and number 16
we have already dealt with I think have
we already moved in
second 15 number 15 sorry you've just
done number 14 yeah oh sorry to okay um
number 15 are there any questions
move and seconded by bar all those in
favor say I against Carri you do need to
do number 16 we have done number 17
okay so number 16 um delegate to group
manager finance and Assurance to make
non-significant Corrections and
amendments any questions around that one
move um and if not then will somebody
move that we do that than St seconded
Lesley um any other discussion all those
in favor say I I against
carried and we did do number 17 number
17 done number 17 thank you okay well
sorry it takes so long in that paper but
it's an important paper and I think it
was it was important we
spent okay Rihanna and the next one is
in your name as well okay so um this
paper provides you with all of the draft
asset and activity management
plans um and it notes the um some minor
changes to the kpis which you had
received earlier in the process it notes
a confirm a following change sorry it it
notes recommended change under four to
the um infrastructure assumption so
that's around the capital delivery
forecasts which are now um have been
refined um marginally from what you
received earlier
um and it confirms changes under um six
noting um that we will bring through all
the changes in the budgets that you've
made at this meeting and flow those
through into the X asset and activity
plans where that needs to be done sorry
to the infrastructure strategy and
addition of two alternative capital
investment 10 years for forecasts one
inclusive of three Waters and One
exclusive of three Waters um perhaps
it's worth noting that b will only be
done if required by
audit which we are now not certain as of
today it will be
required okay so this
paper has got a you know large number of
appendices um the the I think all of
these plans pretty much fall out from
what we have already previously agreed
so I'm minded to take them all at the
same time if everybody's comfortable
with that but are there any questions of
Rihanna good work there's no questions
will somebody move that
we approve is that the word that we
approve all of those
plans y some move thanks Barry seconded
by
Grant is there any other discussion
all those in favor say I I against
carried thank
you so that concludes oh no it doesn't
we've got a the late item item yes late
item which is to receive receive I think
is a word doesn't it we not approving
anything to receive the receive and then
approve okay to receive and approve the
recommendations from the finance and
projects committee so we are receiving
the
minute receiving the report brings forth
recommendation receiving the report and
approving the
recommendation um it's from you m is you
want to see this yes no isn't my name
simply because my team are responsible
for the minute Administration and as
we've said earlier while Michelle is
good she can't turn the minutes around
quite that fast so this is the paper
that's been t
if you're trying to just follow what's
happening um that's the recommendation
that came through from financing
projects um earlier this afternoon I'll
move you'll move is there a second
thanks R is there any other
discussion those in favor say I I
against carried thank
you that concludes the public session of
council rangy you got well I just want
to raise the issue and and I you know
it's important that we are only just a
quorum at the moment of council and we
are running but the risk of that not
actually meeting with uh the various
people leaving um and the business that
we have in front of us is I'm just think
we're running too close to the wire only
if somebody leaves yeah no no no but I
mean we are good now at s out of 13 but
I'm just saying it it does prove a risk
that I think uh we need to be slightly
bit more aware of considering what we've
had to debate and if we were unable
because of the failure to reach cor not
to go through those substantive uh
motions we've just passed it
it's we aren't functioning okay so your
points well M yeah so I just want to put
that on record really thank you can I
can I ask then before we do move into
public excluded whether anybody's
imminently going to run depends on 12:00
tomorrow what time I got a meeting but
okay so we probably get half an hour of
so to go the very most so if everybody's
okay with that and thanks for pointing
out R because it would have been
embarrassing if we had suddenly found
ourself with a quorum thank
you
Pard okay um so that does conclude the
public
session will somebody move that we move
into thanks second Daren
others in favor say I I against carried
thank you so that ends the
live